c'est très simple dans les élections
celui qui l'emportent c'est celui qui a
le plus de voix la progression du front
national elle s'est faite sur le blocage
de nos institutions
l'absence de renouvellement et
d'efficacité des deux forces politiques
majeurs qui exerce le pouvoir en france
depuis 30 ans le ps et l'ump le ps et
l'ump est donc
temps que on
entretiendra les causes de cette
progression la progression peut
continuer et il suffit donc le
ça ne sert à rien de pleurer en disant
mon dieu des progressions d'extrême si
l'on fait tout pour que la progression
des extrêmes continuent
je ne me définis pas
outre
jeudi deux choses 1 la france
aujourd'hui aurait besoin de
renouvellement et de rassemblement alain
juppé peut remplir ces deux attentes
mais il a choisi de s'engager dans le
mécanisme des primaires sur lequel vous
savez j'ai des interrogations parce que
les primaires ça donne la prime sera
plus dur ça peut être un piège pour lui
rhodia en tout cas ces deux à risque
pour pour ce choix c'est tout ce que
j'ai dis je si vous reprenez ces deux
impératifs on a besoin de renouvellement
et on a besoin de rassemblement alors
vous vous trouvez devant le véritable
paysage politique français c'est à dire
il ya des gens qui veulent qui au corps
renouvellement et qu'on se retrouve avec
hollande sarkozy le pen rien à d'autres
qui disent il faut trouver une autre
issue j'appartiens à ceux qui disent il
faut trouver une autre issue
on
e
renouvellement ça veut dire qu'il ya du
nouveau et quand
je dis seulement servent et
rassemblement le savait bien qu'elle a
été mon affrontement avec nicolas
sarkozy c'est que nicolas sarkozy
considérait que ce qui était bon
électoralement c'était d'opposer les
gens entre eux et moi je pense que c'est
bon électoralement il est possible que
ce soit vrai et que c'est très mauvais
pour l'avenir est donc là est une
conception différente de l'action
politique
alors bon
vous avez dit si ici ici et moi je vous
dis je vous dis que vous connaissez ces
deux vieilles chansons avec des si on
mettrait paris en bouteille